we need kong
the world needs him tired of hearing of
that
so yes we have another tv spot tease of
godzilla vs kong
and it got taken down but to be fair
there were only 14 seconds of new
footage being seen on it
so it isn't really the end of the world
and yes you haven't seen
everything and you haven't seen the
entire movie so chill
it's kind of becoming cliche to say that
so anyway it's mostly action sequences
in the teaser nothing much but there are
two really important scenes however
one where mechagodzilla is seen in the
eyes of godzilla
and the other one where we can see the
new skull crawler
and this brings us to question the
entire league plots of the movie
spiraling out of control in the internet
you got to watch till the end
so let's get down to it there is an
important part in the league tv spot
teaser with
two scenes of kong and godzilla looking
at something anyone can say that they
are looking at each other but
that's for the untrained eye but if you
look closely kong is staring at
something that gives out a red light
as seen on his face reflected on his
face well the only thing in the monster
verse that would emit that color of
light is mecha godzilla
or it could be one of the buildings
shining its neon lights on him
but i'm putting my bets on mechagodzilla
then we see godzilla exhausted and
almost
out of the game looking up at something
but seemingly still trying to defy what
was to come
then the shot of godzilla's eyes tell
the truth it was mechagodzilla
reflecting back from the
big g's pupils it seems that
mechagodzilla would have the upper hand
in the battle
and it would only mean that kong would
have to step in and they would team up
to defeat this mechanical monster
another new scene in the tv spot that we
are going to discuss is the one where we
see only godzilla's foot hitting the
ground in hong kong
this is clearly a reference to godzilla
in 1998 when we were only able to see
his feet in new york city
and it kind of adds on to the suspense
of seeing the full design later on
of the 1998 kaiju which was a really
huge disappointment though
but wait a minute if we closely examine
the feed structure it clearly doesn't
look like
the foot of either the most of us
godzilla or
obviously not gong who are supposedly
the only tyrants in the city of hong
kong
it kind of looks like that of a skull
crawler a really big one
at that if you remember the big one in
kong skull island that was around 60 to
70 feet in height
well this one looks to be four to five
times the size just by adjusting the
feet
with the buildings around it it was
teased in the godzilla versus kong toys
that there would be a skull crawler and
it looks like this one would be bigger
and would possess a red patch of skin
that runs down its back
from the head to the start of the tail
we have termed it as the alpha crawler
and maybe it's the creed of the hive and
responsible for the death of gong's
parents
its spot in the movie might be linked to
the scene in the chinese trailer
the one where madison russell was in a
room that was thought to be an
incubation chamber for organic talents
well we weren't that wrong or even that
correct
well we have a confirmation from the
damashi nations events being held in new
york city this week
that these incubation chambers actually
have baby skull crawlers in them
so they could also be eggs too
this would mean that sometime during the
movie humans maybe the apex organization
would allocate resources and capture a
few of these skullcrawler eggs
and store them in a facility and this
might alert the big mama of the crawlers
to come
and rescue her babies and so with that
the scar crawlers in hong kong this
would in turn be a cause for kong to
come and end the beast's life
which would also lead to the ultimate
fight with godzilla so maybe
this is just a theory mind you that
there would be four titans in the battle
of hong kong and godzilla versus gong
that is the alpha crawler godzilla kong
and finally
mecca godzilla so that's it we might be
right we might be wrong but we have come
to the end of this video
hope you liked it and do give a thumbs
up for support and subscribe to be a
part of the mind cue family
and finally smash that notification bell
for regular updates on monster news and
content
right here on mind minecube take care
fam